[Music]
LA's Papa Christos Greek Grill have you
guys heard of this what Papa Christos
what it's a brand deal well you said la
Papa Crystal's Greek grill is our
restaurant yes we have Greek restaurants
here where we used to get get them for
like Jay King his lunch and jqp lunch is
in zank Mediterranean foods that was
Greek oh those ankles Lebanese oh but
it's very similar to my BOB you can't
save it just call my mother
the reason why I bring up Papa Christos
you guys really haven't I never I've
only heard of the mad Greek on the way
to Las Vegas I know a Monte Cristo is it
good what's a Papa Christo's alright so
it's a it's a Greek restaurant here in
LA and it recently went viral because
thanks to this guy right here
ja Rule oh my god it's 50 cent going in
on him oh I can't hard not to count
weight alright so to fill in Steve cuz
he's lost yeah
job role recently went my role because
he did a commercial for Papa Christos
Greek belly dude it is the worst
commercial I was reading the [ __ ]
menu off of the phone it's all bad his
life is over TIFF can you move your
gigantic water bottle please this is
gigantic
Juby he reached the low of the low he
has man I feel bad for now here we go oh
boy why does he look like he didn't even
age - I love Greece on the t-shirt okay
here we go
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay how in the [ __ ] is this
embarrassing this is Jay legendary words
it worked now we know what pub Christmas
is I mean your DJ's gonna make fun of
him
I can't wait controls him oh I love him
this is what he ended up you know their
history I don't know they have beef and
50 is obviously in a much higher place
in terms of success so one of the things
that he did was John roll had a concert
he modeled 200 tickets and then so it's
an empty front like mosh pit front row
area just to troll of that'd was way
back in the day one of fifties friends
robbed Ja Rule's chain and then so when
Charles saw that the guy was with like
the guy who robbed him was with fitty
then I'm so sorry real quickly he robbed
his chain like his restaurant chain or
like a little ashamed o necklace him
Friday big 100 was a big worm it steals
everyone [ __ ] all right [ __ ] it 50
tweeted he said this is what happens
when you [ __ ] with me I'll have you and
your whole label silly
that's a good line that's a good line I
[ __ ] love beauty man the funny thing
is his labels Murder Inc right you can't
doubt like the most gangster sounding
label selling [ __ ] pita bread it's
great I think the contrast makes it that
much funnier I'm really good in the
context of how ja Rule had failure after
failure especially with the fire now
he's just a joke yeah this marketing it
went viral it worked worked how much did
they pay like it was I wouldn't know so
bad what's dope about him though about
ja Rule is that he's not he's not above
it
he's literally down for anything and he
was swinging but gyros bro but but but
but but is it because he's desperate cuz
I probably probably in the dumps me but
he doesn't have an ego because some
people down in the dumps and they're
still not gallon you know what I mean
I've seen those people if he look like
[ __ ] why did this would be different
he's having a blast yeah so I let you
guys run a little bit I don't want to
burst your bubble here no it wasn't out
of desperation he was actually he
actually made this commercial owner for
a celebrity show off like new TBS
reality TV show where famous people
create their own content and compete for
YouTube views so that's the reason so ja
Rule chose to he chose to highlight a
local restaurant so to support a small
mom-and-pop restaurant
Eccleston and so it was for a good cause
and he ended up tweeting out thanks for
making my commercial trend and go viral
with your help we helped raise money for
at no Kid Hungry and helped at Papa
Christos gained a lot of new business
make sure y'all watch celebs show off on
TBS wholesome for a little bit school
thought he was really desperate
I'm surprised Greek people on Twitter
aren't like trying to cancel him for
just pronounce you to Zeki and making
fun of all the names and [ __ ] that like
look at his phone be like what the [ __ ]
is this one that was well okay
makes me want to see the show I'm like
what else is here I want to eat there I
do want to eat there he look pretty good
yeah all of those backdrops look like it
was from the 90s and [ __ ] it was a
pretty bad greens plus having him
there's something funny about having ja
Rule standing on the grill of the food
you're about to eat like throwing heat
is that you huh
making it rain with Peeta it looked like
he was just in socks to how much they
spent on this I know I wonder you know
and then I checked out his IG and there
was also there was he was promoting
doing private concerts like for people
he's like like social distance or kovat
safe performances and it was like a very
tiny intimate little scene so he's all
there like performing I'd be good if he
was pretty bring a shot T though cuz
he's gotta bring a shot T it's not the
same I just I would only hire him if he
was performing but only using karaoke
music he should move into comedy you
know it's like a cool guy yeah I like
him he doesn't take itself too serious
why cause he can't he can't anymore
dude did you guys ever play like [ __ ]
50-cent video games what 50 cent video
game that's how hard 50 cent made it bro
oh my god you did two games I think he
did one called blood in the sand and it
was like it was pretty time you just go
around blasting people who said you said
you're like blasting people yes or you
mean you're the one getting busted no no
you're blasting people for sure you're
blowing them away with all kinds of
different bits his video game it's just
probably him blasting genre over and
over he would do it and then jog be like
tight you put me in a video game
he's like unfazed by any of this which
is actually really cool maybe have been
too many years and he's coped with it
yeah he's just fine he shows that he
cares just enough to keep the game going
well I like the buddies it's an actual
rivalry because we all know about the
celebrity rivalries for publicity like
the Ryan Reynolds versus who the [ __ ] is
it Wolverine Hugh Jackman beef no no no
if it's fake listen II completely fake
with Ryan Reynolds so they like promote
each other's liquor basically and I like
this rivalry too is on it's clever and
it's innocent like he just a do that's
clever yeah yeah like it's not dangerous
no one's life is in danger here it's
just like I'm just gonna [ __ ] kick
you around a little bit yeah that's true
you do lose some street cred and swag
points I don't think they even care
anymore at this point okay probably not
I mean da rule I don't think you baby
buying that [ __ ] out is a good flex man
yeah that's funny it's a good flex on 50
but then on ja Rule I think he lost the
credit let's be real all ja Rule could
do is put his parking ticket on fifty
cents windshields yeah he's like I got
you it is not a back and forth lit it's
literally a lion just biting a mouse and
I think he lost his cred as soon as he
came out with this first music video
wearing a Tupac type vent bandana I was
like [ __ ] this guy yeah you just have
love songs it was good that era was fun
2000s I think he was getting called out
for his wannabe gangster Ness because
like if you watched get rich or die
trying' like there's a jaw root
character in god yeah well he was
basically like ja Rule was like he was a
studio gangster and he was representing
things was he a wangster yeah I think
well 50 was if I remember correctly 50
was calling him out on some [ __ ] that he
was doing and he was being an impostor
and it and it was like in the same
vicinity like the same city it was some
kind of like you're representing my city
some gang [ __ ] whatever and that's when
he went on a full-force
like assault with ja Rule how gangster
is it to do a Steven Seagal movie cuz
DMX did that he oh yeah yeah it was
called the exit wounds oh never mind yes
yeah dude I remember seeing that he did
martial arts and nut sight it was either
exit wounds or it was the prison one it
was the prison one I remember they were
in prison yeah yeah yeah pat pat is dead
half past day one oh yeah dude he was in
that movie with with the gold which was
[ __ ] hilarious
you're saying that right now but none
now I'm thinking I'm like wasn't that
job he wishes you know the movie it was
not job walking okay that would be
interesting if ja Rule will do music
videos and birthday parties can we get
them on JK new and what does it say
about us if we can't even get on my JK
knees point that makes us really bad we
got Pauly Shore here we've already made
it yeah we've got watch the people here
before we couldn't make it I didn't say
that oh we were we talking about him I
just said we got Paulie short a man like
you celebrity dude you know the epic is
if we got Joey from full house uncle
Joey
he was my faith every time I think about
him I think about Alanis Morissette oh
you slide oh that's right that's right
they loved each other
yes yeah she rebranded him big time
hahaha was I go down he's gotta like
that good dick
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]